okay one or two more yeah this president
we hear from a lot of people who see
these briefings as sort of happy talk
briefings and they'll happy talk today
and some of the officials paint a rosy
picture of what is happening around the
country if you look at some of these
questions do we have enough mass no do
we have enough tests no do we have
enough PPE no why would you say that we
have enough answers yes I think the
answer is yes who said no to this I'm
saying this I know you're saying no but
who said yeah we like your ass but do we
have enough master yes sir as we hear
from no one say this you said do we have
enough masks do we have enough tests yes
plus we're developing new tip do we have
enough do we have enough ventilators yes
do we have enough hospital beds yes
we've built 20,000 hospital beds we have
enough hospital beds go ahead Jim let's
go what do you say - you mean you watch
the coverage you know a nice-lookin a
lot of code well a lot of it's nice done
sir no no out of it's not it's a lot of
it's fake news really just when the
doctors think I'm the governor warrior
the governor's reporting out without
tests we don't have a like Basner yet
depending on your air they always say
that because otherwise you're not gonna
put him on let me just tell you
something the governors have said last
night they had a group of Governors 14
governors they were together someplace
and they said it's been unbelievable
what's happened we've been totally
responsive ventilators everyone has the
ventilators they need to a point where
we're getting calls from foreign
countries saying you have all the
ventilators can we get some canned we're
gonna try and help some of these
countries these people have done an
incredible job this is not happy talk
maybe it's happy tough for you it's not
happy talk for me we're talking about
death we're talking about the greatest
economy in the world one day I have to
close it off and we did the right thing
because maybe it would have been two
million people died instead of whatever
that final number will be which could be
60 could be seven it could be 75 could
be 55 thousands of people of that
there's nothing happy about it Jim this
is sad talk this is the saddest these
are the saddest these are the saddest
news conferences that I've ever had I
don't like doing them you know why
because I'm
talking about death I'm talking about
taking the greatest economy ever created
with the greatest numbers we've ever had
in almost every aspect of of economics
from employment to companies to look at
the airlines they were having the best
year now all of a sudden we have to save
them okay there's no happy talk to him
this is the real deal and I've got to
make the biggest decision of my life
and I've only started thinking about
that I mean you know I've made a lot of
big decisions over my life you
understand that this is by far the
biggest decision of my life because I
have to say okay let's go this is what
we learn is when you have hospital
administrators but you have many doctors
that say unbelievable job I watched this
morning and I watched a certain Network
and it wasn't Fox and you a doctor
saying that we've done an incredible job
you just read off these no no no well we
have ventilators we have equipment we
have beds
how about beds I mean Governor Cuomo
just told me a little while ago he's got
plenty of beds in fact I have a hard
time filling Javits Center we built them
two thousand nine hundred beds so that's
not a fair question you're stabilizing
they're talking about reusing PPE no
excuse me
we have masks we have everything and we
were trying to get ready for the search
and a lot of people said it will never
happen Deborah said it you'll never need
that many beds they said we needed
40,000 ventilators 40 thousands like
building a car 40,000 ventilators people
said I felt it too you'll never need
that many guess what we have tremendous
we have with the envy of the world in
terms of ventilators Germany would like
some France would like some we're gonna
help countries out a Spain needs him
desperately Italy needs them desperately
Mexico needs him desperately he asked me
last night would it be possible to get
10,000 ventilators within a short period
of time I'll be able to help out Mexico
no Jim just the opposite of your
question it's not no no no it's yes yes
yes we're in great shape and you know
what
what's happening now is those numbers
are horrible but take a look at the
number of beds we have beds available
all over new york new york really being
the epicenter new york new york has
experienced something that has been
absolutely horrific
I saw Hart's Island yesterday I saw
those people being buried yesterday
fortunately we have the beds and you can
speak to mayor de Blasio you can speak
to Governor Cuomo people are people
can't even believe the job we've done
they can't even believe it and I give
tremendous credit to the military
there's been a military operation with
private people but wait a minute
wait wait I give tremendous credit to
our military to the Army Corps of
Engineers to FEMA to these people the
job they've done is incredible and you
shouldn't be asking for that kind of a
question Jim honest their country don't
believe you shouldn't be asking that
kind of a question you should say you
know what it's been really incredible
what's been a half an hour Jim nobody's
asking what governor let me ask you this
what governor we have more tests than
anybody in the world we have everything
we have virtually every country in the
world calling us asking us how do we get
these tests that you have your testing
is the best in the world how do we get
it they've done a fantastic job and when
you ask a question like that it's very
insulting to a lot of great people